[Music]
all right so I wanted to show you
something so I was on youtube.com the
video website yeah and uh I was watching
some some vids kind of clicking on some
thumbnails and kind of watching some
videos right yeah just clicking on
various thumbnails and yeah like you
know sliding the scrubber yeah through
and watching videos and whatnot yeah you
do that right yeah yeah don't actually
watch the video just I just mean go on
youtube.com oh sure sure yeah yeah so
one of the ones I clicked on was a
huberman video he's talking about how he
believes in God oh he does yes I didn't
think he'd be a god guy see that's why I
was interested it in it like the
thumbnail caught my attention cuz like
what and I clicked on it and he like
it's a 10-minute video talking about how
he prays and how he believes in God and
actually if you look at like if you look
at a lot of the top scientists A lot of
them believe in God cuz like the more I
guess the
more I don't know you pull the wool back
on like what's actually going on you
kind of get closer to God I don't know
so he talks about this right and then
for some reason I went on his
subreddit I don't know why I think maybe
to I don't really know why maybe just to
get more I don't I don't really know
what what I was doing but I was you know
doing a little research and this was one
of the top posts of like the last month
or something like like that click on
it this has to be a joke I think it
might be but this has to be a bit all
right I'm not going to read the title
I'm just going to read it from the
description no dude you got to read the
title come
on anyone else try butthole taping to
manage nighttime flatulence oh it say
tagged as funny non
serious oh so what that's the mod saying
yeah that this is clearly a joke yeah
see but I wouldn't really put it past
it's really good trolling because I
would wouldn't put it past someone that
is all about the [__] protocol you
know me and the MS have been religiously
taping our mouths for months which is
something also I'm [__] floored by
taping your mouth shot mouth taping yeah
I know I know of people who believe in
this I mean I get it but it just seems
like torture doesn't it yeah it's just I
feel like I'd end up
dying I would like lean over on my nose
and I'd be like just suffocate to death
you know it makes me think of uh the
scene in The Matrix when Neo's mouth
just yeah exactly horrifying yeah it has
really helped with our snoring which was
waking us up leading to poor Sleep
Quality but one other issue we are
having is loud flatulence waking us up
mostly mine but sometimes hers to
although she won't accept it now I'm
still believing this because this is
something that happens to me like
sometimes my farts smell so bad that
they actually wake me up and I have
really poor night's sleep cuz I'm
farting all night are you joking no I
actually actually swear to God I'm like
gassing up the like I'm gassing me and
Kelsey
basically it's horrible I wouldn't wish
on my worst
en it's when I eat a lot of C straming
that's when it happens yeah well I mean
just to just to Echo that last night
elen and I were talking and the
conversation was you know I don't know
it was a legitimate conversation we just
talking about [__] in the middle of
it I just let out a trombone just a
[__] and she goes goes
Noel those need to stop she's like
that's marriage
ending
what and I go what no way she's like
yeah she's like that is unrecoverable
that is disgusting marriage ending yeah
she's like stop that holy [__] and I was
proud wow yeah that's a strong one I was
proud keep those going for sure that I
could yeah just blow something up that
would make her go I'm
leaving that's power man seriously erase
all the time we spent together you rip
one and he's like here are the papers
yeah sign the papers goodbye yeah yeah
like yeah sure I'll
sign or what if I fart on it is that
does that count fart on the divorce
papers is this just as good as Sonny
it does that work oh now they
stink sorry now they
stin is that marriage ending
um I have tried a variety of diets but
none of them seem to help me then a
light bulb went off and I was like why
not use a tape why not use a tape at the
other end too dude you're going to
implode seriously the gas goes reversed
yeah yeah comes out lower
intestin no your mouth is tap your nose
and your eyes oh so then your eyeballs
explode um we have both been taping our
rears for about two weeks now and so far
we haven't woken each other up due to
loud flatulence I know it's been only a
couple of weeks but the results have
been promising the only side effects is
I'm extra gassy in the in the morning
that's not how it works I don't think
nah n you got to
release if you don't fart they don't
just like save up they come out as burps
or like they like they got they like you
know absorb into your stomach lining or
something you know you know the the
Drake that type memes yeah they go Drake
the type to to go fart in the toilet
yeah that's the one where I've always
thought isn't that the appropriate thing
to do though normally like go to the
toilet and just fart I mean if you're
but you're saying appropriate if you
have to fart in a public setting you you
you should excuse or or like maybe if
you're dating someone and it's it's new
and it's fresh you're not going to just
blow up the blankets like you're going
to I got to take a piss yeah but I guess
maybe the funny part is making sure to
like pull your pants down sitting on the
toil that's the funny part it is funny
thinking about a fart just like echoing
around a bowl with nothing else in
it you get that you get that really
Hollow you
know it's like it's that it's that Tick
Tock fart was like the Reverb
exactly stop yeah why wouldn't you just
walk into the bathroom and fart yeah go
to the toilet that's the funny part all
right never mind yeah okay I we get it
now I see the difference yeah we get it
this you know it's 4:30 in Tokyo right
now that's what I'm on p.m. a.m. so you
should be
chilling amm damn yeah so you should be
good yeah that's that's that's what time
I'm I'm waking up right now I tried
waking up the other day I went I went
like this when I woke
up why why I don't know alinaa was
laughing her ass off how long's it been
since you got back four or five days
it's just oh so you're not over yet no
it's been kicking my ass some days I'll
wake up at 7 and I'll go till 3: in the
morning I'm fired up H and then that's
it's been a couple days and a couple
other
days uh I'll go lay down I don't know 11
12 I'm just
like just horror film staring into the
ceiling can't fall asleep damn that
sucks man trying the Magnesium [__]
worst yeah trying to stay off the
weed the weed the weed he's trying to
stay off this the lettuce when I saw
Snoop say no more smoke I'm like I
relate man yeah dude I'm off it too
taking my three hits off of an electric
pen yeah yeah I relate cutting those out
yeah yeah dude trying to stay off the
wind